[Music]
my audi does muscle shows for sure my
delts are embarrassingly good today for
the love of gear please just sever me
till season 2 comes out because this
finale was one of the best i've seen in
a long long time in this video we'll be
taking a look at the show's biggest
unanswered questions season 2 theories
that will have you begging for a waffle
party and if you play your cards right
you may even get a handshake thank you
may i have a handshake i've left
timestamps below so you can see all the
topics we'll be covering in this video
and you'll want to like and subscribe
because i'll soon be coming out with a
video detailing all the hidden clues
throughout the season here we go
the finale begins with our innies
successfully engaging in what's called
the overtime contingency allowing them
access to their bodies in the outside
world it's revealed that r is in fact
helena egan the daughter of lumen
industries ceo james egan who we've
actually seen in mannequin form back in
episode 3. her being severed is all part
of a publicity stunt to show how safe
and effective severing can be
this is why milcik is so happy when
helena or should i say helly arrives on
her first day when we heard you were
coming here it was like a miracle
it's amazing what you're doing it's also
why we see him taking photographs of her
in the office throughout her stay the
act of severing is highly contentious
with several states banning the practice
altogether so helena has taken this
drastic step to show the world how we
shouldn't fear it the problem is
severing is cruel helena's innie is so
desperate to escape she tries to kill
herself but i think there's something
deeper here that helena is also doing
this to appease her father as we've seen
in the hall of perpetuity lumen ceos all
belong to the eagan family although we
haven't seen the real helena in the
outside world she must have a tremendous
sense of familial obligation and pride
something her father reiterates to her
the grandfather would cherish what
you've done the grandfather here likely
refers to kier egan the founder of lumen
and fun fact the name kier derives from
gaelic meaning the dark one helena
ironically means shining light in greek
while heli literally means hellish check
out this shot here where we can see the
word hell clearly made out i guess it
makes sense then that the first image we
see of helly is of her on a
coffin-shaped table in an episode titled
good news about hell speaking of
helena's father i should also mention
that those who attend the break room
often recount hearing something in the
background while reciting the
compunction statement that weird apology
thing helly recites into the mirror
dylan says that when he's in the break
room he's heard a baby crying which
could be one of his two other children
if milk chick is to believe that dylan
has three kids helly however heard the
sound of a mumbling angry man could that
person be her father in her brief
interaction in the outside world were
also reintroduced to gabby and angelo
arteta gabby was the woman devin met who
underwent severance so she wouldn't have
to live through the pain of giving birth
her husband is a pro-severant senator so
it makes sense that someone like helena
and the eagans would want to be close to
people in positions of power in helly's
final moments as her audi she proclaims
to everyone at the egan family gala that
everything they know about severance is
a lie and that the innies are being
tortured now this may seem like a deeply
calamitous event but keep in mind this
is a private friends and family of the
egan's event this little blip can be
easily covered up plus if anything does
leak to the media it's likely to be
suppressed as lumen seems to have
insiders in all aspects of the media on
march 18th apple released a companion
book to the tv series called severance
the lexington letter i'll leave a link
to it in the description below for those
interested it's a tell-all story about a
woman who was able to bypass the code
detectors and pass along notes to her
audi she reached out to a reporter at a
newspaper to tell her story and expose
illumine but one of the editors there
suppressed the story the name of that
editor jim milchek if this book is to be
believed it implies that seth milchik
has family on the outside that also is
involved in covering up lumen's
nefarious deeds perhaps even more
mysterious than helena is irving's audi
on the inside irving is arguably keir's
biggest supporter being able to recite
passages from the handbook from memory
and a stalwart rule follower it's pretty
interesting then that on the outside
he's the opposite trying to expose lumen
let's take a look at some of the
interesting things we find in his
apartment first there's his dog radar
this was actually hinted at back in
episode 3 when irving attends a wellness
meeting your audi likes the sound of
radar irving also has a number of what
appears to be military medals we aren't
sure if these are his or those of his
fathers who seems to have been in the
u.s navy if irving was in the military
it's possible he chose to sever to
escape some form of ptsd in fact art
therapy is one of the ways in which ptsd
sufferers process traumatic events in a
new way i'll get back to his black
elevator paintings later on in the video
but the big shocker here is that irving
has a locked chest filled with
interesting goodies first is this news
article about a man suing lumen for
workplace injuries claiming that lumen
hid the real cause of the loss of
feeling in his finger he received a
letter on his windshield explaining that
it was due to a printer-related injury
similar to when mark got one on his
windshield after heli threw an intercom
at him more importantly is this list of
severed employees that irving has been
tracking here we can see dylan g's name
but it's actually the names we never see
that are more interesting there is no
mention of miss casey or mark's wife
gemma scout and i'll get to why that may
be in a bit it's completely possible
that irving has or was working with
former lumen employee pedi and or ragabe
in episode 3 pity tells mark that
someone helped him escape and that there
are people out there wanting to expose a
lumen this could be ragabe irving or
both petey even says to mark that at
lumen i'm your best friend
you're my very good friend this is such
a weird thing to say it's almost as if
petey is implying he has a best friend
on the inside that isn't mark and that
person could be irving along with the
employee list is a map of kier
pennsylvania with a number of locations
of kear employees or at least that's
what's implied considering bert goodman
the man irving fell in love with on the
inside is on that map now it may be
coincidence but all the names on the map
are men irving will later drive to
bert's but has his heart crushed to see
him with another man and it's going to
be super awkward when bert opens the
door to find irving who is banging on it
transformed back into his regular audi
self in season 2 expect us to find out
more about irving's investigation at the
end of episode 7 we learn that miss
casey the wellness counselor is mark
scout's wife gemma it's only when he's
transported to the audi world that he
finds this out and that she's still
alive the whole reason mark chose to
have his life severed was to escape the
pain of dealing with his wife's death
the first scene we see of mark is him
grieving her in his car using a tissue
to wipe away his tears a tissue he'll
find in his innies pocket and throw away
like nothing into a nearby waste
receptacle a metaphor for him throwing
away his grief but as his sister tells
him this is only a band-aid solution for
something much larger forgetting about
her for eight hours a day isn't the same
thing
as healing if mark is truly going to
heal he'll need to realize that
severance isn't the solution there isn't
much we know about miss casey she
supposedly died in a car accident but my
guess is that lumen picked her up to be
experimented on after all lumens started
as a healthcare company and likely owns
many hospitals unlike the other
employees we never see miss casey in the
outside world i believe she never leaves
lumen that dark hallway with an elevator
that only points downward that may be
where she lives in episode 3 petey says
he found a department at lumen where no
one leaves and on his map he has a
section that reads some people might
live here if this is the case miss casey
lives in a perpetual state of severness
never being able to return to her real
outy self if a company were able to do
this to one person think of the effects
it could have on millions jane egan
tells heli that he one day wishes every
person on the planet will have one of
these chips in them which hints at what
lumen's end game is full control and
this leads me into what those numbers
macro refinement spends all their time
inputting for more insight into this we
have to go back to the lexington letter
i mentioned in the first section in it
the ini whistleblower notes that she
finished a macro refinement file called
lexington at 2 30 pm just two minutes
later a truck belonging to a lumen
competitor dorner therapeutics exploded
destroying several dorner devices and
killing six people although the
whistleblower concedes this could just
be a coincidence the timing is very
close could this encrypted data the
macro refinement department sorts be
triggering dangerous events in the
outside world such as a bomb going off
hence the secrecy behind their jobs this
may also explain some of the items we
see optics and design creating with
their 3d printers it's noted that last
week they were instructed to make items
that were quote particularly violent
these included hatchets but this week's
it's watering cans so who knows the
numbers themselves are sorted into four
categories w-o numbers that make you sad
fc numbers associated with happiness and
joy dr numbers that scare you and m a
numbers that make you angry these line
up with cures for tempers woe frolic
dread and malice keir believed the four
tempers make up every human soul and
depending on what kind of race you have
it determines your character it is said
that kier was able to tame these tempers
which gave him power and that power he
wants to pass on to his children the
four tempers are represented in physical
form by the weird dancers dylan is
treated to after his waffle party one of
these is a goat and goats appear all
over the show most notably in the goat
department and in weird background
sculptures historically goats have
symbolized everything from virility and
sacrifice to satanism so it's not really
clear yet why lumen would have a whole
area reserved for raising them one of
the more interesting characters this
season is miss cobell or should i say
selvig who straddles the innie and audi
world at face value it seems like she's
a valuable lumen employee even telling
helly before she goes on stage that what
she's done will result in her and the
other innies being tortured but there's
another theory out there that frames
cobell in a completely different light
one that actually has her being lumen's
worst nightmare tell me more we know
that cobell has a shrine to cure or at
least that's what we think it is what if
it's actually a shrine to her mother we
get this brief shot of a breathing tube
and a hospital tag with what appears to
be her mother's name in the lexington
letter we learned that these breathing
tubes were made by lumen and they had
defects so could miss cobalt be planning
revenge on lumen for the death of her
mother this would explain her huge
freakout after being fired she had spent
years working her way up in lumen
undercover gathering info and now it was
all going to be for nothing by stopping
hallie and calling milcek to interrupt
dylan kobel is maneuvering her way back
into lumen i mean they have to bring her
back as a reward for single-handedly
stopping what could have been one of the
most disastrous events in lumen history
this would also put her in a position
next season to control the innies and
work alongside them to bring lumen down
one of the weirdest moments in the
finale was when mark and patton
discovered devin's baby and patton
hustles past mark exclaiming to everyone
that he was the one to find the baby
first like who says that who even cares
so long as the baby is found there is
something almost childlike about all of
rickon's friends we have rebecc who has
a bird who pecks at her head patton who
can't even recall why historians before
world war ii didn't call the great war
world war one because world war ii
hadn't
happened yet of course that's absolutely
duh and everyone seems infatuated with
rickon's obviously terrible book but
when audi mark meets rickon it's like
he's meeting his hero that's because his
book the uur has become a sort of
anti-lumen handbook for him remember it
has lines like
your job needs you what if rickon's
friends are all severed people who have
been reintroduced back into the public
with wiped memories hence why they don't
have a lot of basic knowledge and have
warped opinions that have been shaped by
their lives at lumen patton saying he
found the baby first is like him wanting
to be rewarded for doing a good job just
like workers at lumen are rewarded with
egg and melon parties for their good
work this would also explain why they're
also taken in by ricken's book because
it's giving them alternate opinions
about the world other than the ones
they've been indoctrinated with so is
everyone shipped i don't think so
however i think a lot more of them are
than we're led to believe there are two
other things i want to mention before we
end the first is when james egan says
the words the revolving james egan tells
helena that he looks forward to her
being alongside him during this event we
don't really know what this is but it
seems to be some sort of ceremony if i
were to hazard a guess it's when a new
successor takes control of the company
perhaps at the old successor's death and
the old one becomes remembered as a wax
mannequin in the hall of perpetuity jane
would pass on the ceo title to helena
and the process becomes like a revolving
door with one egan family member
replacing another the second thing i
want to discuss which has huge
implications for season two is mark
telling devon about lumen this is our
first non-lumen non-severed individual
who now knows about the dangers of this
program she's also just found out that
her sister-in-law the person who helped
make her brother quote-unquote wonderful
is still alive expect her to join forces
with some of our other characters to
take lumen on i had an absolute blast
watching this first season i will be
coming out with more severance videos so
be sure to like subscribe and leave a
comment on your thoughts and theories
about the show below thanks for watching
everyone for more bad takes you can
catch me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt and until next time
remember
let's burn this place to the ground
you